bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 sport l'émission
consacrée à l'actualité sportive dans le
département tout de suite on passe au
sommaire tennis de table un ce tournoi
caritatif en faveur du togo était
organisée ce dimanche à plaisir équipe
nationale togolaise étaient présents
pour ce rendez vous amical et détail
dans cette édition baseball mélissa
maillot joueuse de 16 ans qui a fait ses
classes aux cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux vient d'être
présélectionné pour jouer dans la ligue
américaine
elle est la première femme de l'histoire
à participer au tournoi de détection
européen pour nous parler de mélissa
maillot nous recevrons dans quelques
instants son frère dylan coach adjoint
de montigny et la président des cougars
amy cotton bay tant que cette discipline
est aujourd'hui tendance chez les jeunes
de moins de 30 ans pour décrypter cet
effet de mode de nous avons suivi à
christophe délit périgny montant de 29
ans pendant le tournage de gens courent
une compétition organisée ce week-end
reportage à suivre
et puis en fin d'émission nous parlerons
du football féminin et de l'impact de
l'équipe de france sur les résultats des
clubs locaux
je vous le disais dans les titres 85e
pongistes ont participé à un tournoi de
tennis de table caritatif en faveur du
togo
la compétition était programmé ce
dimanche au gymnase et qu'elle de
plaisir les meilleurs joueurs togolais
étaient présents lors de ce rendez-vous
et lady moigne pour les images ça me dit
85 pour gist se sont affrontés à coups
de lifter de coudre au gymnase eyquem de
plaisir le club de tennis de table de la
commune organisé pour la deuxième fois
un tournoi amical caritatif en faveur du
togo
objectif récolter des fonds pour
développer cette discipline dans ce pays
tous les bénéfices du tournoi sont
reversés intégralement
la croix rouge française pour des
opérations comme n 1 39 entraîneurs au
togo pour le développement du pays
notamment à la fois pour former des gens
qui vont développer le tennis de table
au togo lors d'émissions qui réalise
l'été et aussi pour collecter du
matériel de tennis de table pour les
équiper de l'année dernière c'est la
première édition on avait collecté 750
euros qui ont été versés à la croix
rouge et cette année dont convient de
faire les comptes avec le trésorier
on a eu 85 participants et on aura à peu
près mille 100 euros de bénéfices qui
seront reversés à la croix rouge pour
l'occasion une dizaine de joueurs
sélectionnés en équipe nationale
togolaise est venu participer à ce
rendez vous caritatif
je suis vraiment ravi de voir un tournoi
socialement paul au togo franchement
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on voit
souvent
donc je suis vraiment
radio fait d'être hors déficit offerts
dans les idées un tournoi qui n'a
d'amical que le nom les joueurs français
et togolais ont joué à leur meilleur
niveau pendant la compétition
moi je parle numéro 2 du tableau
aujourd'hui mais il ya plusieurs joueurs
internationaux du togo des joueurs qui
en dit long et numérotés français le
numéro 1 des dents les joueurs qui fait
partie des 200 meilleurs français qui a
fait le choix du monde donc c'est
vraiment très très intéressant et c'est
un plaisir de jouer des bons joueurs
comme ça après le succès rencontré
pendant cette seconde édition le tournoi
devrait être reconduit l'année prochaine
l'objectif c'est de la pérenniser dans
le temps donc ça fait un deuxième année
on espère continuer et à chaque fois de
pouvoir progresser un peu dans
l'organisation n'aurait prochaine notre
projet c'est de pouvoir se délocaliser
un gymnase plus adaptée accueillir du
public avec des tribunes et après
pourquoi pas le faire homologuer pour
que vraiment ça attire beaucoup plus de
gens du côté des résultats comme imao
aussi à veytaux glow s'est imposé en
finale dans la catégorie toutes séries
devant baptiste paul et tête de série
numéro 2 chez les féminines julie
chevallier d'elancourt a terminé
première devant florence gossio de
voisins-le-bretonneux les couillard de
montigny-le-bretonneux ont perdu ce
week-end contre le leader clermont
ferrand sur le score de 16 1 dans la
première manche et de 15 à 4 dans la
seconde
deux défaites qui ne remettent pas en
cause la participation du club aux
play-offs pour dresser le bilan de la
saison de montigny nous recevons sur ce
plateau la présidente annie couteau et
l'entraîneur-adjoint dylan mahieu annie
couton la saison est plutôt belle malgré
cette défaite contre contre clermont
ferrand oui c'est une bonne saison nous
avons atteint l'objectif que nous étions
fixés en début de saison c'est à dire
atteindre les play-offs
il nous reste à confirmer cette
quatrième place voire peut-être une
troisième place avec le déplacement à
rennes la semaine prochaine des
placements qui a été déjà repoussé deux
fois du fait des intempéries sur elle
donc la semaine prochaine devant
remporté deux victoires et peut-être
qu'avec ces deux victoires nous
pourrions passer à la troisième place ce
qui nous intéresserait quand même mieux
pour les problèmes pour les play-offs
car ça nous empêcherait de rencontrer ou
clermont ferrand car si nous restons
quatrième soit obligé de rencontrer le
premier ce qui sera quand même un peu
plus difficile dylan mahut est ce que
vous êtes satisfait du rendement de vos
joueurs oui après bon ya pas deux
y'a pas de honte à perdre face au leader
du championnat donc on avait un objectif
en début de saison c'est d'aller en
playoffs pour l'instant il est maintenu
on verra ce week-end prochain
et est ce que vous avez vu peut-être
certains un petit regret sur certains
matches qui aurait pu tourner en votre
faveur
oui on a plusieurs matchs qui aurait pu
se finir
on aurait pu finir gagnant vainqueur
mais au final on perd sur des petites
erreurs durant le match des fois ça se
joue à la dernière manche
bon c'est bête mais ça arrive ça arrive
à tout le monde et dans quel secteur
vous avez peut-être pêché cette saison
c'est peut-être la maturité de l'équipe
l'équipe est assez jeune est-ce que
c'est peut-être ça qui a fait la
différence
on a une équipe jeune mais ça reste
quand même
des jeunes qui ont du potentiel et qui
savent jouer au baseball donc c'est pas
vraiment ça qui nous a fait défaut je
pense que l'on manque beaucoup de
frappes en manque
on manque beaucoup de situations de jeu
qui doivent être basique qui ont
combattu en irak beaucoup de choses
simples un écoutons par rapport aux
derniers championnats est ce que ce
championnat est finalement plutôt bon où
est ce que vous le mettez plutôt dans un
championnat moyen ont classé comment ce
championnat il est plutôt bon parce que
nous avons quand même une petite
difficulté cette année on a un peu une
difficulté sur les lanceurs surtout sur
ce dernier match qui nous a manqué c'est
notre lanceur titulaires qui lance
toujours monsieur white qui lors du
dernier match à eysines a eu une
fracture du poignet et c'est vrai que là
son absence se fait cruellement sentir
donc je pense que nous manquons de
lanceurs puisque nous sommes avec rennes
une des deux seules équipes qui n'ont
pas recruté de joueurs étrangers à
montigny comme nous étions fixés comme
objectif nous jouant qu'avec des joueurs
formés au club que les joueurs du cru
que des joueurs du cru
nous refusons d'être une équipe qui va
chercher des joueurs à l'étranger voir
ou même ailleurs en france
nous voulons jouer avec notre des
joueurs que nous formons d'ailleurs nous
sommes reconnus comme un club formateur
la suite du reportage vient de prouver
et c'est une question de budget aussi
également se finir premier ou dernier ce
championnat est ce que ça joue
énormément le budget du coup le budget
ne juge pas sur le classement
le budget joue sur le fait d'avoir
d'aller chercher des joueurs ailleurs
nous pourrions avec le budget que nous
avons nous pourrions recruter des
joueurs étrangers mais ça serait au
détriment des jeunes et ça c'est quelque
chose que nous refusons nous voulons
quand même que nos jeunes puissent
participer à différents tournois à
travers la france voire même à
l'étranger
et si nous faisions le choix de recruter
des joueurs étrangers s'attelle c'est à
dire que nous mettrions environ 20000
euros dans le recrutement de joueurs
étrangers et nous n'aurions plus ce
budget là pour les jeunes et ça ne
voulons pas et si vous êtes qualifier en
playoffs
dylan est ce que vous pouvez les
remporter ces playoffs ou monter dès
cette année je pense qu'avec une équipe
complète
une équipe sérieuse une équipe complète
on s'entraîne bien les bonnes les bons
entraînements je pense que pour moi on
peut le faire il ya pas d y a pas d'
équipes qui sont vraiment vraiment au
dessus
si clermont sont clairement des bons
joueurs mais sur la longue
voilà ils ont plus de matches que nous
et c'est donc après bon pour moi moi je
ne fais pas de souci je sais que les
play-offs on peut les remporté sans
problème n écoutons ça serait une bonne
chose la monter financièrement peut-être
peut-être pas cette année peut-être
parce que après la montée je crois qu'il
ya encore des matches barrages nous
devant rencontrer le
joueur de division l'équipe de division
une qui est dernière mais je ne pense
pas que la montée sera pour la saison
prochaine peut-être que dans deux ans
oui nous pourrions monter mais pas tout
de suite et vaut mieux pour mon team
peut-être de monter dans deux ans plus
tôt que cette année je pense je pense
que dylan partage ma bon sentiment je
pense ça aussi car on a des joueurs
jeunes comme on l'a dit donc il manque
un petit peu d'expérience j'essaie des
choses ça qu'il faut absolument de
l'expérience au baseball savoir ce qu'on
a à faire sur le terrain c'est important
l'actualité du baseball en france et
également dans le monde c'est la
présélection de milices un maillot 16
ans ancienne joueuse des cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux au mlb européenne
élite campe 2015 pour faire simple c'est
une pré sélection pour intégrer le
championnat américain le meilleur
championnat du monde
elle vient par la même occasion la
première joueuse de l'histoire à
participer à ce camp annick août on est
ce que pour vous c'est une surprise ou
est-ce que vous vous attendiez à ce que
cela soit présélectionné non s'attendait
pas à ce qu'elle soit présélectionné les
gros sûr que c'est une grosse surprise
qu'ils aient présélectionné une femme ça
c'est une grosse surprise
après et si on considère mais les salles
comme un joueur de baseball sans
considérer le sexe c'est vrai que ce
n'est pas une surprise parce que en
france elle a un niveau qui est
nettement supérieur à des garçons et
puis deux ans depuis deux ans elle a
intégré le pôle france à toulouse où là
elle a beaucoup est là elle s'est
entraîné tous les jours et elle a
beaucoup gagné en qualité de jeu mais
c'est le fait que la mlb
et enfin daigné regarder une femme c'est
une résolution plutôt vers le soft
balles assassines oui c'est une
révolution culturelle pour les
américains comme ç'avait été une
révolution quand ils ont sélectionné le
premier noir jackie robinson
à ce moment là à ce moment là tout à
fait je pense que c'est ça et c'est
peut-être ce qui fera que une ligne une
franchise va vouloir la faire signer
parce que c'est pour eux c'est un
événement qu'une femme puisse intégrer
une équipe professionnelle de baseball
dylan vous êtes son frère comment vous
l'avez appris où vous l'avez appris et
comment l'avez vous partagez en fait m
on l'a appris
un petit peu plus tôt que les autres car
on a été comme si la famille on a été
appelé par les américains comme quoi il
va se passer donc cet événement là que
moi elle avait présélectionné par la
major league pour faire des tests pour
pouvoir jouer peut-être dans ce camp
professionnel et donc nous on a été
pareil surpris c'est vraiment c'est
super j'ai pas de mot à dire vraiment c
c'est super de jouer comme ça d'ouvrir
les portes à tout le monde et voilà et
ça mayenne nous l'avons contacté juste
après l'annoncé de sa sélection pour le
camp européen on l'écouté je suis super
comptable deux skiffs pas parce qu'on a
toujours été mon but d'aller le plus
loin possible dans le baseball
après je suis un peu frais par tout ce
qui peut se passer parce que tu apprends
à leur terme avant avec le baseball mais
viens de me rendre compte peut au final
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui parlent
comme moi quoi un écoutons il ya un réel
engouement autour donc de sa sélection
on l'entend elle est un petit peu
stressé par l'engouement que suscite sa
sélection comment comment faire pour
pour l'aider est ce que ça peu la
paralyser peut-être je ne pense pas
parce que mélissa c'est qu'il y avait
une grande sportive elle a vécu quand
même beaucoup de matches dans lequel les
gens la regardent et ne serait-ce que
l'année dernière de ce que nous sommes
allés au tournoi little league en italie
est un tournoi qui est organisée par la
major league et elle est et il y avait
des équipes de toute l'europe et elle
était la seule fille parmi parmi toutes
ces équipes et c'est vrai que les gens
la regardent et beaucoup mais sa passion
c'est jouer au baseball dans quand elle
rentre sur le terrain je pense qu'elle
oublie qu'elle est une fille et settat
c'est un joueur avant tout dylan la
famille maillot va vraiment l'encadré
vraiment là la soutenir sur les
prochaines semaines pourrait s'être créé
peut-être je sais pas une espèce de
cocon autour d'elle pour qu'elle puisse
se concentrer sur ce qu'elle sait faire
jouer au baseball ouais on essaie on
essaie de la rassurer
c'est vrai qu'à 16 ans quand on est pris
par les médias tous les jours etc
c'est compliqué à gérer mais bon
s'agisse pas trop justement non à ces
acquis se référencer elle a des
personnes qui sont là pour elle est là
la famille qui est là aussi les amis
c'est vraiment à faire la part des
choses et pour moi la la elle a pas de
stress à avoir parce qu'elle est
vraiment bien entouré vous voyez comme
une chance d'être sélectionné 6 tout
comme un fardeau
ce qu'on peut lui coller l'étiquette
peut-être de la fille surdoué qui doit
absolument réussir vous voyez comment
c'est un fardeau c'est finalement ouvert
ce ne sera pas un fardeau parce qu'elle
a pas ce tempérament mélissa je pense
qu'elle va aller capable de passer au
dessus c'est une réelle chance pour elle
même si elle n'est pas prise dans elle
le dit même si elle n'est pas prise dans
une dans une ligue elle elle aura
l'expérience et ça va lui faire avoir
des connaissances elle va profiter elle
le dit elle même elle va profiter de
tout ce qu'elle va pouvoir retirer de
ceux de ce camp mais je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui la regardent ne
serait-ce que même pas aux états unis
elle avait été avec dylan ils ont été
invités il ya deux ans il avait été
invité au japon déjà les japonais depuis
quelques années la regarder elle a été
invitée aussi par l'équipe du canada
donc le canada aussi la regarde donc je
me fais pas de souci pour elle elle aura
toujours des débouchés à l'étranger et
elle est tout à fait capable de gérer
cette pression
mélissa maillot nous la voulons avions
rencontré il ya deux ans et déjà rêvé
d'accéder à la ligue américaine
on l'écouté on va bien pouvoir jouer
jusqu'à 18 ans en france et après
pouvoir partir à l'étranger dans une
université pouvoir faire quelque chose
pour l'instant je me débrouille j'arrive
à bien faire les deux mais il ya des
moments où ça devient compliqué il faut
parfois nous fait des entraînements et
c'est quand même une folle qui reste
prioritaire à wil façon sans école on
peut rien faire mais dylan ce qu'on se
concentre surtout dans cet hymne
services et qu'elle garde les pieds sur
terre malgré malgré ces facilités dans
le baseball et son niveau de jeu oui
comme je vous dis est fait vraiment la
part des choses et c'est ce qui est
assez ce qu'elle a à faire et c'est que
c'est important d'obtenir un certain
niveau d'études pour pour pouvoir être
bien au cas où ça se passe mal on sait
pas on n'est pas à l'abri d'une blessure
ou de quoi que ce soit s'il rentre en
france qu'est-ce qui fait la question
après bon voilà donc c'est pour ça elle
est obligé d'atteindre au moins le bac
quel est son bac et après pour atteindre
repartir tranquillement dans un pays où
pour un juge du baseball peut-être cette
année astra sélectionnés selon vous dis
là pour moi je pense que je pense que ça
peut le faire
il n'y a pas de raison que ce soit un
lanceur français ou américains ou
n'importe quelle nationalité elle est
vraiment est vraiment dans le jeu et
pour moi il n'y a pas de souci elle
pourrait le faire cette année
après on sait pas on ne sait pas ce qui
peut arriver mais ça ça peut venir je
pense qu'enis à mes yeux il jouait sa
survie de très près merci à vous d'être
passé sur ce plateau on continuera à
suivre vos exploits dans les semaines à
venir est peut-être une montée pourquoi
pas dès cet été pourquoi pas on croise
les doigts en tout cas pour montigny on
passe maintenant au terrain de pétanque
une compétition de pétanque était
organisée ce samedi sur les terrains de
boules du centre sportif les trois
mousquetaires lui en cours parmi les
soldats soixantaine de joueurs présents
des jeunes de moins de 30 ans se sont
inscrits à la compétition
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
pratiquer ce sport la pétanque est même
en passe de devenir un phénomène de mode
de mode en ile-de-france le montage
essayer de l'excellent romain respini
terminé l'image un peu vieillotte de la
pétanque ce jeu typique de marseille
prend un sacré coup de jeune
ces derniers mois ce sport est même
devenu tendance auprès des trentenaires
de la région ile de france christophe
délit perry 29 ans habite
montigny-le-bretonneux joueur de rugby
dans sa jeunesse se pointer n'a pas
hésité à troquer le ballon ovale pour
les boules en métal qui reste quand même
joué pendant que mon nom ça fait quatre
ans 80 ne vais pas jouer il reviendra
j'aime bien les gens extérieurs
la pétanque c'est un jeu qui est
qui est convivial on rencontre des gens
moins étant jeune je faisais un sport
collectif et si ça me permet d'échanger
avec plusieurs personnes et je rencontre
le côté compétition c'est un jeux
d'habilité donc est ce que tu es
compétition que j'aime bien dans la
pétanque
aujourd'hui christophe s'entraîne deux
fois par semaine au club de boules de
montigny-le-bretonneux licencié depuis
2014 il s'inscrit également à des
compétitions tous les mois
samedi dernier ligne montrent un
participer au tournoi de guyancourt au
centre sportif les trois mousquetaires
une compétition la moyenne d'âge dépasse
la cinquantaine mais sa passion pour la
pétanque qu'ils fassent tous les clichés
je reconnais qu'il ya la moyenne d'âge
des plus âgés qu'eux qui manage mais on
rencontre quelques jeunes et puis bon de
rencontrer des personnes âgées c'est
sympa aussi
il ya beaucoup de conseils il ya du
métier et d'expérience et ce en
discutant avec ces personnes là qu'on
apprend quelques techniques si on gagne
si on perd on va prendre un coca
et puis on discute de ce qui était bon
pas été bon pour progresser pour les
plaines partie par christophe affronte
désormais son père sur les terrains de
boules de saint quentin en yvelines
une véritable surprise pour ce puriste
licencié à montigny-le-bretonneux depuis
j'aurai beaucoup qui me suivrait un
petit peu mais c'est un peu parce que
j'ai joué à la pétanque quoi il a joué
au rugby tout ça mais maintenant il
s'est remis à l'eau
éliminé en quarts de finale en
doublettes ce samedi à guyancourt il
devra encore peaufiner son geste pour se
mettre au niveau des anciens après les
terrains de boules direction maintenant
leur aide et leur rectangle vert avec
les féminines le football féminin
vous le savez l'équipe de france de
football féminin a été éliminée vendredi
dernier en quarts de finale de la coupe
du monde
score final un but partout mais 5 tirs
au but à 4 pour les allemandes
cette défaite a été suivie par plus de 4
millions de téléspectateurs dans
l'hexagone pour nous parler de cet
engouement autour du football féminin
aufeminin nous recevons sur ce plateau
olivier humble cucchi le président du
club de montigny-le-bretonneux laura
boussiquet 12,2 à montigny michel
cyprien dirigeants de l'équipe féminine
de me voisins et cécile 15 joueuses à
voisins le bretonneux bonsoir laura
boutiques et j'imagine que vous avez
regardé le match
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé c'est un
très beau match de coupe du monde avec
deux belles équipes qu'elles sont là la
france et l'allemagne mais dommage pour
nous pour le résultat mais c'était un
très beau match très beau match de foot
cécile vous imaginiez déjà au début la
compétition que la france avait soulevé
le trophée à ce que vous n'êtes pas trop
déçue d'échouer
oui après on espère tous que notre faim
que l'équipe de france
enfin gagne c'est qui est normal mais
après bon ben il ya eu beaucoup de
déception et puis après vigeo vision du
match constate cried démérité pas quoi
le match a été suivi par 4 millions de
personnes
olivier est ce que ça vous surprend cet
engouement pour l'équipe de france ça
fait maintenant quelques années qu'il
faut ball féminin il démontre qu'il a
une grosse qualité au niveau du jeu on a
quand même les équipes
de championnat de france qui maintenant
ont été championnes d'europe avec lyon
mais j'ai été en finale encore cette
année donc on commence à avoir un beau
championnat de france
et quelles sont les réactions des
spectateurs quand il regarde pour la
première fois un match de football
féminin
généralement quand il est là voisins il
y z en pense quoi les gens sont surpris
souffrent moi je vois titre personnel
avec ma compagnie que c'est pas du tout
le football est maintenant à s'y
intéresser le regard des mesures pour
revenir sur le match de france allemagne
j'étais impressionné par le rythme du
match est joué avant au début c'était
pas aussi rapide et aussi technique
c'est les gens qui découvrent le foot
féminin justement apprécié ce côté plus
technique avec moins de cinéma je dirais
sur le terrain voilà c'est le jeu pour
le jeu et au niveau local ça se ressent
vraiment ce les résultats l'équipe de
france pour l'instant bas actuellement
et c'est encore un petit peu trop chaud
parce que en plus équipe de france est
éliminée donc je pense qu'il ya pas mal
de personnes qui ont accusé le coup au
niveau 2 au niveau du foot féminin
mais il faut encore un petit peu
attendent au niveau des inscriptions
pour avoir vraiment un état qu'on crée
de la situation reste quand même très
loin des 1 million licenciés en
allemagne à la 75 mille en france
comment l'expliquer ce chiffre pourquoi
on est ici en retard par rapport à
l'allemagne
alors là c'est vraiment je sais pas
c'est dans les mentalités peut-être dans
l'éducation sportive au départ peut-être
à l'école où les allemands sont très
sportif dès le départ donc peut-être
nous on n'y est pas encore assez et mais
bon la fédération française a tout fait
virer pour favoriser le foot féminin
beaucoup d'être beaucoup dead alors on
en parlais avec mon collègue avant
l'émission
c'est un peu au détriment je dirais de
la qualité peut-être il ya beaucoup de
clubs qui se sont créés en foot féminin
est maintenant ben je dirais sur la ne
serait ce que sur la ville nouvelle il
ya cinq clubs
tous les deux ont pour cela même chose
pour ce qu'il y en a il y en a trop quoi
il faut essayer de se faire des ententes
se grouper et pour essayer d'améliorer
justement cette qualité et favoriser
l'engouement je pense
laura est ce que
vous en tant que joueuse vous comparer
par exemple à gaitan signer où vous
allez ici parce qu'elle vous motive
peut-être candidat le faisait à l'époque
avec les garçons je me compare pas
vraiment aux joueuses je suis contente
que je suis plutôt l'évolution de
certaines choses que j'ai pu rencontrer
sur des terrains soient joués avec
certaines je sois contre moi ou j'ai pu
rencontrer à l'école parce qu'il ya des
joueuses avec qui j'étais
j'étais à la fac donc je suis plus je
suis plutôt contente de voir l'évolution
est de voir qu'elles ont pu atteindre le
haut niveau est plutôt que non identifié
aux joueuses mais c'est bien de voir
l'évolution donc justement défi qu'on a
pu côtoyer et de voir qu'elles ont pu
devenir professionnel pour certaines
est-ce qu'il ya déjà des joueuses qui
sont venus vous voir des jeunes joueuses
qui sont venus nous voir en disant je
veux devenir louisa necib leur boulot il
n'y a pas encore cet effet là encore bah
moi personnellement non maintenant moi
ça fait pas longtemps que je suis
football féminin donc je m'y intéresse
de plus en plus malgré qu à montigny se
fait quand même plus de 30 ans
maintenant que la section a été créée je
pense que laura serait plus à même que
moi à répondre car elle est aussi
éducatrice au niveau de la catégorie u13
donc moi personnellement non
mais je sais que je pense que les filles
ont les mêmes rêves que les garçons de
toute façon et qu'est ce qui manque pour
faire une entente
ici à saint quentin en yvelines qu'est
ce qui manque et six mois que tout
nouveau président c'est évident d'y
répondre mais je sais pas peut-être
peut-être qu'un jour ça pourrait se
faire déjà dans un premier temps c'est
peut-être réunir tous les présidents de
clubs et ensuite mettre ça autour d'une
table et puis pourquoi pas avoir un
projet commun
avec la ville nouvelle on sait qu'on a
quand même des sacrées installation sur
la ville nouvelle que ce soit voisin
montini ou trappe donc c'est quelque
chose qu'il faudrait peut-être
envisagent à l'avenir
vous en avez envie leur vie danville a
envie d'essayer de faire quelque chose
oui ça c'est sûr et le soufflé de cette
coupe du monde de cette effervescence
vous pensez qu'il peut redescendre
non je pense pas parce qu'il ya des
chaînes dieu merci les chaînes de la tnt
qui est qui se bat un peu pour
retransmettre les matchs féminins est
bon la tnt gratuite donc c'est pas
réservé à des privilégiés et les gens
qui découvrent bon ben il regarde un
match et bae
ils sont surpris de la qualité donc il y
retourne et comme j'utilisais avec le
président de montigny on peut dire merci
aux hommes qui nous donne pas toujours
le bon exemple sur un terrain donc on
retrouve un petit peu les valeurs du
sport quoi les valeurs du football
initial c'est ce que je pense cécile
vous quand vous discutez avec votre
famille partent entourage au regard a
vraiment changé sur sur sur le football
féminin vous ils en pensent quoi en fait
votre famille de ça vient de mon père
donc nous a toujours encouragé c'est sa
femme et par enfin y'a pas que mon père
mes parents mais c'est vrai que mon
entourage ne connaissez pas le football
féminin
au début ça fait 25 ans que je joue au
foot donc au départ c'est un peu
difficile à dire à une fille qui joue au
foot
maintenant c'est tellement médiatisé on
en parle lui même les personnes viennent
regarder les matchs enfin nos propres
matchs et ils ont une autre vision du
football féminin trouve ça plus gracieux
moi moi comédie donc non séance ils sont
agréablement surpris en fait sur le
football féminin foot merci à vous kahn
est repassé sur ce plateau on l'a
compris l'avenir du football féminin est
plutôt radieux pour les prochaines
années en passe maintenant aux autres
résultats du week end
est à l'honneur ce week-end à saint
quentin en yvelines la vie de guyancourt
accueilli l'open des yvelines de
taekwondo un art martial d'origine sud
coréenne au gymnase de l'aviation une
compétition dans laquelle le club de
guyancourt a brillé parmi les principaux
résultats corentin des molles est arrivé
premier dans la catégorie des moins de
49 kg amin kahli lui monté sur la plus
haute marche du podium chez les moins de
30 kg sabrina jouanno la président du
comité départemental nous dresse le
bilan de cette journée très bon enfant
beaucoup beaucoup nos troupes c'est fait
pour eux les débutants on a eu pas mal
de clubs il y avait cent quarante cinq
compétiteurs
c'était vraiment une super journée
autant pour eux pour les spectateurs
pour les compétiteurs coach et pour
toute l'organisation qui est derrière
nous pendant que guillon court juste mon
avis qui nous reçoit qui a eu sur une
dizaine de compétiteurs inscrits il ya
eu 7 7 médailles football à présent
direction la major league soccer le
championnat de première division des
états unis orlando city l'équipe du
fontenaisiens aurélien collin s'est
imposé contre les colas aux colorado
rapids à domicile et floridiens ont fait
la différence grâce un but du brésilien
kaka l'ancienne gloire du milan ac a
permis aux joueurs d'orlando de doubler
la mise trois minutes après l'ouverture
du score de laruns l'yvelinois aurélien
collin n'a pas pris part à cette partie
à cause d'une blessure le joueur qui
porte le numéro 78 pourrait revenir sur
les terrains d'ici deux à trois semaines
du côté du classement orlando et 5e de
la conférence est à un point de la 2e
place pour refermer cette émission de
dates à cocher dans vos agendas l'open
de france de golf débute ce jeudi au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et plus grand
golfeur de la planète s'affronteront sur
les greens dans les têtes d'affiché on
note la présence des français victor
dubuisson avec sang et or la vie le
nord-irlandais graeme mcdowell 48e
mondial et double tenant du titre sera
également de la partie
enfin l'allemand martin kaymer vainqueur
en 2009 et lee westwood 30e mondial
tenteront de soulever la coupe
si vous voulez assister à ce grand
rendez vous il reste quelques places en
vente
il y aura de l'athlétisme également
cette semaine un meeting départemental
est programmée ce vendredi à partir de
18 heures au stade mont boron de
versailles
au programme de la perche des lancers de
poids du marteau du saut en longueur et
des épreuves de vitesse
il s'agit également de l'ultime
préparation pour les athlètes cadets
juniors qui auront championnat de france
ce qu'un jour après une compétition qui
sera organisée à valence
c'est la fin de 7,8 sport merci d'avoir
suivi je retrouve lundi prochain pour
une nouvelle émission
s'il a passé une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv fil 78